what we don't talk about a lot is the
UFOs that are living under the sea Muto
unidentified
submerged and they said it's around the
Bermuda Triangle Christopher Columbus he
said a light was under the water like
there's no lights in 1470 whatever why
did we change it to UAP instead of UFO
unidentified flying object now
unidentified anomalous phenomena here's
why because they are what's called all
domain space air and sea unidentified
anomalous phenomena covers all domain so
you see no inertial effect which no
slowdown from space to air to se and a
good example of that would be the
Tic-Tac UFO event with Commander David
frer have they tracked them moving at
high speed underwater yes 100% so the
resistance of the water isn't an issue
correct